and the great thing with Logan oconor he can
go from 12 minutes to over 17 and doesn't miss
a step he skate so well McKinnon will give it
up push to the near side dreway got cut off at
the boards Dave's now at the point one one down
deep and there's a blocker save by hellu and he
had to get there centering pass and the ABS are
fortunate that Kyle Conor couldn't get that quick
shot off parked himself in front of the net and
sort of forgotten about there's a redirected a
saate by gorv as he closes the pillows and that
was very good that was an unreal tip by Kyle
Conor coming through the hash mark spectacular
save by gorv again we talked about him at the
pregame show so underrated is Kyle Conor maybe
not in Winnipeg but around the nation Hockey
League when you're talking about some of the top
Wingers not often is his name put amongst the best
but he is that good and he's got a borderline
fabulous mullet as well he's got lots of hair
probably leads the NHL and mullet's S hair on
the near Side Long Shot there saved by hug he
looks like sort of a maybe a guy from Game of
Thrones something like that am I wrong that's
it out front shot save by rebound off the body
of wood who's laying at the top of the crease
into the Avalanche and nice play by Tatar to
get a stick on that one and there's Stanley I
saw him during pregame skate right girl explain
more momentarily shot save by goria puck bounces
to the near side will take a timeout 1305
go here in Period number one we've got no
score Ryan Johansson able to get his stick in
the way up it comes long shot there that's way
wider than net Stanley centery pass shot save
point blank by Alexander gorgi 42 to go here
in Period one we've got no scor at ball Arena
you certainly want that out of your captain
to the half boards and that one's LIF it up and
out in a foot RAC is bym he's in front of Baron
to steer the puck to The Far Side we get help
man but the puck has turned over to the near
side shot what a save by gor first still
no score but Winnipeg threatening down the
ice R to get loose mckin with the backand
shot that goes through the greas Jack Johnson
racing here's mckinn looking shooting hit a
body off Escape B that stop by hellu you'll
hold on good as there is in the National hocke
League just watch this comes in the edge work
to slide around like that and get that wrist
shot off and earlier on that backand the way
he spun around was remarkable look at him barely
hanging on to that left Edge three guys on him
sticks everywhere Logan oconor takes that right
in the gut and then ra here comes back in front
another whack at it he's just gum be coming
across little kale M back it goes for Dr moo
again threw it up a skate 8 seconds left
here in the first period on page gave it
away centering pass shot score an absolute killer
with 2.2 seconds left in the first period the EVS
had the puck in their own end in a three-on-one
situation and they gave it away to Perfection de
just has full control of that Puck and cannot
get it up the wall you can't sugar Cod that's
just an error on t one of our best defenders the
best plus minus dmen over the last four years in
the NHL Devon just gets a minus mistakes happen
that's a tough one at the end of the period Adam
Lowry so
predictably that through not out of the Zone moris
he keeps it alive that's through Conor elers bumps
it for Connor turn around shoty scores Kyle Conor
32 seconds into the period makes it a two nothing
game he'll do that he'll fire fire from anywhere
and all of a sudden the ABS caught flat footed in
their own end car blows a tire in the far corner
and when he does he just can't get back in time
right there to Kyle Connor who spins around and
just slides that right on net the way that he can
do it and the apps now really got a hold to dig
out it with the way that the winnter piig Jets are
playing and it's pretty quiet here in ball Arena
con DS in Far Corner RAM for Stanley he's got
time and space that is up and out rookie m now T
right to McKinnon he'll race in down the McKinnon
backand he scores Nathan back top shell back can
B down and the ABS yet within one it's a 2-1 game
is McKinnon his 10th goal of the Season well that
pass was Perfection McKinnon comes in just catches
big stly flat footed which isn't hard at 6' s
and does a little jingle and look at how perfect
that back hand in where the crossbar and the post
where they weld it together is where he tuck that
puck Perfection top shelf and just like that mckin
has life B and Byron back to get it out away from
shley momentarily finds M Glass and now a foot
race back to the one zone racing it is tario shoot
save by hellu short side and remember folks Thomas
tar 29 goals when you're at the Montreal Canadians
he knows what he's doing he comes in just tries to
sneak it short side look he's looking left and may
have committed too early right easier for me to
say as he's flying in snapped off from Mory now
it's shley big kill turnaround shot save rebound
knocked away pucked up in the air bang that and
it's Logan o Carter turns it to the forehead
and hard off the glass it'll go all the way
down mckinon on the four check but here comes
Dylan tried to find neider does shot save Nino
NE Rider Strong able to scoot it out and out of
the box comes Dylan the ABS 0 for two two shots
on goal in that power play H turns in front save
another save another save oh my goodness three
kicks at the can and the last one went off the
side of the Nets reward them after it they'll
continue to keep that up as we roll on 545 great
back check there by bardi morisy couldn't find the
Stick of NE Rider now Nino has it all the way to
the point Mor's wide open there's a blast and he
scores Josh morsey an absolute bomb for his fifth
of the season the Jets have taken a 31 lead he's a
great shot you'll get a good look at it here at
home you can see gorv sees nothing everybody's
in front screening away and that far right hand
side is wide open and morsey absolutely picks the
pocket BB ahead by Dylan irum gloves it down sends
it out kib Ron now the right wing it's McKinnon
trying to get around Dylan in the hip check
McKinnon staying with it in front score no did it
hit the crossb I thought kimy Rona knocked it top
shelf I thought it was back post Mo I didn't hear
it ding did it go off the back pad I don't know
shot glove save goria did that not go in the net
I think it did take a look folks Nathan McKinnon
Blows By the outside loses the puck gets it over
to K Rona miles wood goes in and here's the Moment
of Truth yeah that's in baby score that is back
top shelf this will guarantee it for you folks
miles Wood's out of the way I can't fathom there's
goenda of any kind there K Ron's second goal of
the Season boy good job K Ron you know he had a
goal and two assists in his second game from the
call here we go re the crowd's going to ER with
31 seconds left on the clock the P fully cross
the goal line we have a good goal and there you
go 790 2525 B since good lawyers changing lives
final 40 5 Seconds sent up top intended for Byron
stolen by Kyle Conor he'll skate to an empty de
score oh that's that's going to do it drewan was
so good all night long great plays all night
long an exciting finish to this game where we
hope the ABS would be able to find a way to get
it to overtime as you see KY Connor come in and
Blasting his 17th and it's y tying 17th goal of
the season now 5 seconds left Stanley will eat
it and that will do it here tonight at ball Arena
well the Jets came in we can see there for real
you got to bring your aame and just like that
only two points behind in the central standings